here at the beach house they're agreed
with John Crotty Jax at their choice you
you catching the flippin snuffing it and
here's drog it's the vision going right
up stick double Skywalker's hair pan and
Jones junior hero beretta file the
cutting chunky save that sequence
[Applause]
excellent first attack draws to cease
Jones jr. down the middle and he's got
enough space to operate right there I
just love the vision from BAM to be able
to be unselfish enough to deliver that
pass and then coming into your living
room right there is the Jones jr. Russia
nama heat looking young 15-point lead
for the second time the night for Miami
bands of the gall
FIO with six points in this quarter BAM
get news strong finish right there over
the rookie and then catching it on the
move again he's a good young head coach
Butler threw it away to be Andre hunter
what a trek down Smackdown for Penn this
is all about the track down it's Pam
coming flying the Andre hunter never
sees him and he just mothers it right on
the glass the heat trying to get to four
and OH and the procedure as you get a
2-3 zone Jones junior finds miners
mattered he slams a throwaway he just
tore apart back to the offense side here
for Miami
excellent feet on the interior as Meyers
Leonard cuts again we talked about him
getting into the open air he's never
stationary allowing the defender to get
in front of him he finds an open spot
makes Hiro has a great range of water
annamaria it's a head for Dillon Brooks
and a terrific track down rejection by
Rizzo gotta be much more proficient with
the basketball some real careless
turnovers to drop it for Jones jr. the
[Applause]
shooters Derrick Jones jr. catching on
the fly and balance unis late to rotate
and that's what happens right there when
you meet that man late and inside the
restricted area that is just dunking
goodness right there airplane mode at
its finest
throwing it down literally because he
couldn't get all the way to the basket
he becomes the eighth player in
franchise history to score at least 20
in his heat debut Silva will not back
down he's a hard-nosed guy hustling back
making a play John Moran exposes the
basketball there by rearing back with
the right arm that's just a good block
see how open right there Moran's body is
instead of trying to close it down and
maybe finished with the left hand
[Applause]
potentially a game saving block man came
flying in like Superman let's--oh had no
idea this is a bust out dribble right
off the glass he coasted to slow down
and here comes Beckham with a
spectacular play Bucks were seemingly
shocked by this four six pick in June by
Minnesota culprit for towns
good contest again by Chris Silva we got
a piece of that shot slow in the
rebounder but he'd have dominated the
last three and a half minutes
[Music]
second-year guards six feet ones
electrifying on the offensive end
getting to the spot after helping out
when Lent opens up to dunk with that
right hand that gave Meyers Leonard the
opportunity to use his right hand on the
ball the Hawks defense keep it a minute
DeAndre hunter the rookie from Virginia
had his duck derailed by the long arm of
payin antibiotic they had coming out of
nowhere and again able to clip it
without fouling which has 13 points off
the bench
Silva this for a gusto dunk nice bounce
pass setting up the side pick-and-roll
in his he's head high
he's airplane modish there now look at
cephalo she had the right idea let me
get out of the picture
[Music]
James said the the big 17-point came at
home against usin dragons a triple damn
the third quarter and he wants more
[Music]
a big game Thursday 4th quarter net late
in 46 games there's none breaking free
[Applause]
this month including their current full
game skin Butler with a backdoor cut
head seed crushing dunk by Leonard and a
foul play of the game not get Jimmy just
laying this one out after drawing - and
here comes the hammer by big Thor right
there look at that Jam some sort of
rebounding balance underneath where you
might come up with it
[Applause]
BAM on a quick catch and go move and
then you want to come over and help you
better bring your luggage cuz this guy
right here will Pike it on your head he
is just so athletic and strong all
Shemin of his free throws 68 points for
the Rockets Dillon turnover against Iggy
this is restroom
and track down situation from my
Kendra's none making a play on a runaway
type situation for Westbrook one of the
more athletic guards in the league the
butler guarded by chris dunn butler goes
right but there comes in after hero
[Applause]
beau puts the shooter Tyler hero in the
pic so he pops back to the three if they
double-team Jimmy he's left open and
that's exactly what happens Tyler no
hesitation again instead of BAM sent it
it's the shooter Tyler hero and he
flares back Jimmy keeps his composure on
the drive and kick back and oh my I'll
tell you this guy has confidence beyond
his years John first of all he said a
terrific screen his second of all
cold-blooded the perfect release it
brought rain and pilla Chicago
[Applause]
[ __ ] us Angeles Lakers the fourth rated
team defensively in the league
[Applause]
second-to-none
not a deal well just get him to his left
hand right off the curl pass
that's BAM doing a nice job and against
you
it's the switch guarded by Duncan
Robinson with eight on the shot clock
Butler comes over on the double-team and
LeBron with another turnover a pie
turnovers in last night's game and Miami
was terrific scored 19 points off
turnovers Oh Leonard with a crushing
duck oh he took out the hammer dive cut
Jimmy Butler looking around with the
probing dribble porzingis ball watching
trying to help on Jimmy and that gave us
we'll have some more coming up from raw
then rewind plus we'll get the second
half plan with will man so and Dan Craig
back to live action with John Adair
Derrick Jones jr. with a ferocious
finish their hero good rebounding rookie
is third board of this first half
there's Hiro laughing oh what a play
Jones jr. with a catch and reverse-flash
15 left first half three-point in the
end they might have to raise the roof in
Miami if Jones jr. keeps flying around
to remain over holiday rate visual
communication here Kendrick none seen
the opportunity and the hard cut on the
baseline as Derek Jones just jumps right
over
Aaron holiday he's six feet there and
James Johnson passes that eat me to
school Jones jr. for three ferocious
dunk for that a pile it's a three-point
game
[Applause]
beats diliman 2-3 zone hollis-jefferson
pumped no path and here come the heat
its dragons with VanFleet and help
[Applause]
who's fallen it's rockets seeing the
cutter
silver going up high with the crusher
[Music]
eight straight points for the magic they
lead by 13 with 822 left
BAM underneath against Bamba oh hey over
the 7-footer mo Papa's a willpower dunk
for BAM attaboy this is just pure
physicality look at the my the pivoting
and then that's on a seven footer a guy
taller than him has to push him out of
the way pivot and then pull you know
right now they are so poor defensively
than ever every night they seem to be
getting
[Music]
but 22 points again I care how you get
him he's still get me shooting a high
percentage is official
[Applause]
better slam for ban that is just
gorgeous
simple but look at the boulder Tama that
help and that sets up the lob activity
excellent one hand catch with that big
breed with John karate Jason's action of
a fox board son crew Tyler here opens
the fourth quarter in the lineup for
Miami second on the shot clock
they have missed it Jones shouldn't the
word instinctive he is just got great
timing coming flying over two Spurs and
oh by more hurdles gonna have nightmares
about that one he is just looking at
some steel and a half a game there's
kids with no lobbing for bad crushing
tongue the most important hooked up to
the game that brings will heat to within
two radius the passes behind him he had
to go back with his offhand and chorale
it in it's got to be quick
[Applause]
types of a second last name page right
here he fakes the pass and goes right
over the top and credit BAM for crate in
the space from Cory Joseph there they
didn't put a longer player on BAM which
is surprising they switched and that
allowed the heat to go over the top and
court truck it's put that Paul in
perfect position they chose to put
length on draaga CH instead of on BAM
Adebayo
and that's what allowed talk about that
emotionally and objectively and very
honestly I'm sorry for the passing of
the Great Commission oh my what a great
stuff for James Johnson James Johnson
showing his full skill set getting on
top of the rim and 45 to 30 Washington
in the second hand BAM Adebayo
back in gets it from dragons puts a hole
BAM Adebayo gourd drug is trying to sell
the hard drive as he goes between the
legs here so he freezes me eat me who
can't recover back to BAM it's it's a
well time play where he opens his legs
there doesn't want to Telegraph the
patch so heroin green with 11 points a
piece off the bench to leave the
Clippers
[Applause]
Florida MO Harkless just couldn't get to
I mean what a finish right there BAM
[Applause]
this much often from Kelly but he times
this jump perfectly right before it's at
its apex for that block one of six
beyond the arc at seven for gays their
leading scorer BAM already has two
triple doubles this year about that BAM
slam at an an 82-game season last year
hook with the 25 he's had up until today
o 19 and 6 back to Jimmy right gucci
boots this is Aaron Gordon come on that
dragon that shot it goes out of bounds
off Gordon that is the best defensive
play of the game
he's coming on the gyro it's a slower
move and then BAM is able to swat it off
Gordon right there the inexperience gave
Vincent a two-way player get a chance to
play tonight we have
waiters on the bench so speculated that
he might be part of the trade is killed
source to the rim and smashes it come on
how about that play by Pam modify oh and
then your big that's your Center
17-point lead for them it was a two
point Sacramento lead at the half oh and
out of bio eruption all it looked like
bowling pins inside watch the three
kings just scatter as he finishes on top
of the basket the unbelievable power and
athleticism with the crushing put go
Baron jail and threw away the key
it is Jam of the game over the two-time
defensive player he has yet to
relinquish that wall he's done such a
good job as a sport oh my
pretty simple with the interruption a
jump around the store 18 points per game
and help lead that 30 and 11 second half
of the season Derrick Jones jr. with a
catch and smash point lead through one
corner
rockets recognizing there's no shot
blocker and he finds the airplane bo
Derek jewels on the dive cut to the
basket really nice free look at that
catch radius game this season
draaga CH on the keeper lobs it for
George Jr he batted it in and drew the
foul he released early of them here he
is just making a second effort almost so
19 of Dallas's 30 shots have dumped them
through traffic using the OL in extreme
return to screener that's beautiful
pendant will work draaga ch2oh look
rockets with his second assist
halfway through the third quarter
deflection loose ball picked up my dirt
Jill junior ahead for babe look out boy
points off your defense / - natee - run
out it's that long arm of Derek Jones
initial contact then BAM gets a hand on
it boy those are the kind of run out
opportunities you want who was waved
three times traded twice he's relentless
competitive four corners Rogich as he
turns the corner here on Harris gets the
left hand floater up and it's clearly
out of his hand before the buzzer goes
off you never know when you're gonna
need those extra two points
dragons comes up with a big bucket
they're so Miami already with three
double figure scorers led by the
fearless dragon goran dragic 11 points
five assists Devonte Graham only one of
the first quarter then just two or four
from three of a 17-9 what a play by
Derrick Jones you